foreign
[Music]
may I please see the map now seriously
you won't let me hold it for even one
minute nope not even for one second come
on Kitty you've got to trust me
wait wait wait what's what's going on
with his eyes oh they're getting bigger
oh Kitty you gotta trust him look at
those eyes really you call that cute no
oh look at her those eyes are even
bigger than yours do whatever she wants
puss wait a second so
[Music]
no
with the paws come on what the heck it's
all so cool
can we look at the map now
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] boots
you are down to your last life
you need to retire
oh brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommate well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend this is a person party that's
your party so this is where dignity Goes
To Die the year start coming and they
don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either you're
funny what's your what's your story my
story
what are we looking at can't have nine
lives
now I am on my last laugh oh no
legendary
wish waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great posing
boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish look at me my
life's back okay okay possum face I
won't make you back but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
[Music]
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie there's all
right let's get it over here
[Music]
without life to spare I am nothing when
you only have one life that's what makes
it special go get him tiger hey take it
easy
just gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
foreign
[Music]
thank you